If you're sensitive to flashing images
I'd give this entire video a
miss because it's full of them.
Hello there, I am Gav,
in this video we'll be
learning how a 3D TV works,
using the help of slow motion as usual.
Specifically the kind that use these
active shutter 3D glasses.
Should probably start saying
this is how a 3D TV worked,
because they're now relics of the past.
This video is sponsored by KiwiCo,
I'll tell you more about them at the end.
Before we look at the TV specifically
let's just go over the basics
of what is actually going on
when you watch a 3D movie.
When watching content the illusion of 3D
is achieved by showing two
different perspectives,
one to each eye.
This process is usually
started in the camera
either by using a special
3D camera with two lenses,
or by using two cameras side
by side to mimic the positions
of two human eyeballs.
For our VR180 series on Oculus
for our regular speed footage,
we used a camera with two lenses,
and then for the slow-mo
we just use two Phantoms,
side-by-side.
Now the Phantoms are
actually physically too big
to get that close together
especially once the lenses were on.
So we used a special mirroring,
one camera looking through a mirror
and one looking off the
reflection of the mirror.
And this allowed the
Phantoms to effectively
phase through each other,
giving the correct interocular distance.
From experience, I can
tell you that this method
introduces a lot of extra
costs and a lot of extra time
needed to complete the shoot.
I also wouldn't recommend
handheld shots with this setup.
So now we have our two
different perspectives,
left and right eye.
The next challenge is only showing
the correct perspective to each eye.
In a VR headset, it's
actually quite simple.
You just have each eye
look at a different screen,
or look through a different lens
looking at different
areas on the same screen.
I won't go into too much
detail about the other methods,
there's great videos online already.
But in a movie theater you would typically
project both perspectives using
differently polarized light
and then un-powered glasses
would filter those correctly
into each eye.
You can also use Anaglyph,
which typically uses
red and blue filtering
to show each perspective to each eye.
We actually use this out in the field
just to make sure our
footage was looking correct
before we could properly
get it into post-production.
But it is a pretty ugly
way to view 3D content
because the colors are
just all over the place.
That brings us onto this TV.
It's actually a plasma 3D TV,
which I bought secondhand off Craigslist.
It's not in great condition,
there's all kinds of mess happening
on the left side of the screen
and the stand is taped
on with a bit of gaffer,
but it should perform
just fine for this demo.
The reason I went for plasma
is that we can actually
get a bit of a double whammy here.
I've shown how CRT screens
work, OLED screens work,
and how regular LED LCD screens work.
Never had a plasma TV before
and the way they work
is slightly different.
Like an OLED TV, each
pixel is self-emissive.
They don't need a backlight,
but they refresh the screen
in multiple pulses per frame.
The entire screen can't
be lit at full brightness.
So it ends up doing very
short duration pulses
of different information in the frame
Persistence of vision in your brain
causes you just to see the complete image.
This is known as the sub-field drive
which often occurs up
to 10 times per frame.
And the pulse is seen to last
slightly different lengths
depending on where they
are in building the frame.
Here I've stacked the results
of each individual pulse.
Without even realizing it,
your brain will have stitched
all of these together
creating what looks like just
a normal frame of a movie.
Based on what we're
seeing here this plasma TV
probably would have been
advertised as a 480 Hertz display,
but that doesn't mean it's capable
of displaying 480 frames per second,
it just means that it's a 60 Hertz display
with eight pulses per frame.
So the way this differs
from an OLED or an LCD TV
is that in slow motion,
you can't actually see
the entire frame at once.
So now if we switch to 3D mode,
to the human eye without glasses on,
it looks like both perspectives
are just blurred over each other.
However, if I turn up my
shutter speed on this camera,
removing a lot of the motion blur,
you can see that they're
not just stationary
sat over each other,
it's flicking back and forth very quickly.
So now we know that once
the TV has completed
building out one frame, it
then switches perspective
to the other eye and builds the same frame
from that perspective.
This is where the active
shutter glasses come in,
and their job is to
make sure your left eye
only sees the left frame
and your right eye only
sees the right frame.
And it does it by doing this.
Using a battery inside to
power liquid crystal technology
inside each lens, very
similar to what you would find
in an LCD TV.
It switches back and forth
blocking the vision from each eye.
This will happen 60 times
per second, per eye.
That's 120 switches per second,
even on films that are only playing back
at 24 frames a second.
Looking through the
glasses here in 3D mode
slowed down to 20,000 frames per second,
we can see that the TV now
only has the capability
to pulse three times per
eye for a total of six.
And I assume the remaining two pulses
are used to switch between
left and right eye.
Well there we have it.
I honestly think that's such
an interesting way to show
a different image to each eye
because the concept is so simple.
It's really just using
technology to perform
advanced winking.
It honestly makes me a little bit sad
that the technology has
been abandoned for new TVs
because you can get such big
TVs now for so much cheaper
than they were back when this
technology was being used.
And this makes more sense to
me to have on a much screen,
otherwise it kind of looks
like you're watching a film
in a box that's like a foot deep,
it doesn't make as much sense
to me on a small screen.
Yeah, I never had one,
I guess I'm a part of
the reason they went away
because I never bought a 3D TV.
This video was sponsored by KiwiCo,
very happy to have them
back as a returning sponsor
to our videos.
They create fantastic
projects and toys for kids
designed to introduce them to
Science, Maths or Engineering.
This is a Eureka Crates,
so please enjoy some footage
of me building some headphones.
KiwiCo have a campaign known
as small today, big tomorrow.
The idea being that small lessons today
can mean much bigger world
changing ideas in the future.
So by teaching the skills
of innovation, creativity,
problem solving today will
help them get a head start
better in the world in the future.
I've done several of these crates now
and my favorite thing about them is that
everything you need is in the box.
No need to go to the store,
you just plop down a crate,
open it up and get going.
And it's very satisfying not having to
rummage around for extra things.
If you would like to support KiwiCo
and The Slow Mo Guys channel
you can get 50% off your first crate.
That's any of the crates
by going to KiwiCo.com/SlowMoGuys50
for 50% off.
If you found this video interesting
feel free to slop a like on it.
And if you like Slow Mo in general,
make sure you subscribe.
Thank you very much for watching
and I'll see you in the next one, goodbye.